[Music]
on so many levels you are so hot on many
levels yes tell me about this dream Wow
thank you just go and talk about the
dress umm it's Ralph Lauren Couture it's
beautiful and my jewelry is Lorraine
Schwartz Wow you're presenting tonight
here at the Golden Globe how much fun is
that to be able to come to the party and
kind of get that hang at the party but
there's no pressure great because you
don't have to do anything you walk out
with that beautiful statuette and you
give it to someone who well deserved but
you talk about the most amazing
performances of the year and get to look
pretty it's so much fun Baywatch is
coming up this summer are you excited
for that I'm really excited I'm sure the
bad girl yeah that's what I'm excited
about
after Quantico which now is moving from
Sunday to Monday by the way after
Quantico and playing such a good girl on
Quantico I'm really excited about being
the baddie in Baywatch yeah but you're
good girl was confusingly bad for a
moment there on quiet you know I like we
were confused we didn't know what's your
good girl where's your bad girl
everyone's great
there's no black and white on the planet
Alex is definitely great
[Music]